here's a little bit of Piers Morgan
talking about what's happened with
Prince Harry and and sort of related to
Meghan Markle once she got in the the
family most outrageously of all Harry
and Megan allow claims to swallow about
racism in the royal family for almost
two years they made a six-hour
documentary about it they accepted a
human rights award last month for
fighting structural racism in the royal
family all based on what they told Oprah
Winfrey but now Harry's decided
apparently that's not what they meant at
all
in the Oprah interview you accuse
members of your family of racism you
don't even well the British press said
that
right
I did Megan never mention were there
racists
she said there were troubling comments
about she was concern about his skin
color right wouldn't you describe that
as essentially I wasn't not having lived
within that family the way the British
press reacted to that was fairly typical
neither of us believe that
that comment
or that experience
or that opinion was based in racism how
was she dangerous because of the need
for her to rehabilitate her image that
made her dangerous that made her
dangerous because of the connections
that she was forging within the British
press and there was
open willingness on both sides to trade
of information and with a family built
on hierarchy and with her on the way to
being Queen consort there was going to
be people or bodies left in the street
because of that
bodies left in the street there's a guy
who boasted about killing 25 Taliban
actual bodies that he left in the street
and then boasted about it which is now
enraged the entire Muslim world but
Camilla was apparently dangerous because
she forged relationships with the media
says the man who's pocketed over a
hundred million dollars by forging
relationships with media entities like
Netflix Spotify Oprah Winfrey James
Corden CBS ABC And So It Goes On
he says his brother the Prince of Wales
attacked him because he was riled by
reading stories and metabloids but also
that his brother placed those stories in
metabloids himself he slams a memoir by
Diana's Butler Paul Burrell as one man's
self-justifying self-centering version
of events my God the irony of this
from a man who's literally just produced
these single most self-justifying
centering self-centering version of
events imaginable so I don't want to get
too In The Weeds on on Megan and what
she said to Oprah and all those things
but in essence they claimed that this
that skin color was an issue within the
family right or with these kids going to
be darker than other people in the
family and everything else they then
accepted an award for going after
structural racism within their family
now he's kind of backtracking but the
reason I'm playing all of that is you
have someone like Elon Musk who came
from a highly abusive family who was
obviously an awkward kid interested in a
lot of things that maybe the regular kid
wasn't so interested in and he became
something incredible and became a
fighter and is doing good in the world
and then you have someone like Prince
Harry who's worth you know he's got to
be worth 60 million you know they say
around 60 million but like it's just an
endless amount of wealth and he runs
around Western media sobbing about his
family and his circumstances and the
race he comes from and how terrible the
hierarchy of the of the family is in all
of these things
[Music]